こんにちははじめ社長です今日はまあネタという部屋の改造ですね
この撮影ベアをちょびっと方改造しようと思いますますが何かというと
グリーンバックっていうことでございますグリーバーというのは簡単に言うと合成
みたいなものですコースね僕まで昔ちょびっとだけ使ったことあるんですけども
めちゃくちゃ緑色医師の背景
しっとりだけポツンとおきますどうぞ
ちゃんですみたいだけど全部切り取ってその人だけをこっちに抜けるそういう技術が
あるんですけどもう僕はグリーンバッグですねちょっと魅力を感じていますこれからの
時代は地ためグリーンバックだと僕は思ったんで
青いカーテンをよっこらせと他にも館でついてなければるそこにこのパーでは移して
今日から僕はでずつグリーンバックをこの先
研究シッティングていく使う
ようになります誰がいることが難しい男ままを好んで行ったんですけどまぁ結論的に
言うとどうカーテン買えますよ
[音楽]
んよしはいこの問題4はずと僕の家が特定できるよ
ぜひ行ってみてね
このマニーこの緑色八尾首掛けなんですけどもう透けちゃうんだったのでレーザー歩行
時にダンボールを打って
が早いわけしてからリンパ久留米強いカーテンここに貼っていくことをございます
aname
ani
ino
うざいなぁ実はじゃあなはいこれでそれぞれ
おりませんが完了したねちょっとガーデンこのローこのたび完璧な焦点にしてからピー
パックを貼ります絶を
[音楽]
追ってプレゼン多分あっリーグ入りここからですここからグリーンバックな緑べ r ね
これ買って大きさがあるかをれますこれは何ですねより配管やそこに打つ音以前を補給
が更生できるように既に黒バギー主体を北にありと思っ
本当にします谷口長はちゃんとにつれで貼ってから障害者の食感
[音楽]
ブーブーつかどうか
face ちょっと子様合成の練習をしてうまいこと出せるかどうかくる利用して後ろ
実はねその動画で効果バット使いとになりたいと思っています
ば手始めにちょっと軽く分身してみようか始め
影分身の術
んあとっ
ぽッぽッぽッぽッぽッぽッぽッ
俺はぁ
ああああああ2
goo
気持ちはない
[音楽]
ビーフい
ええええええ
t 4